seventy seven-year-old Bernie Sanders is
officially throwing his hat in the 2020
u.s. presidential race or is it the 2024
US presidential race or is it the 2020
USSR general secretary race his memory
these days just isn't what it da long
live the revolution comrades we will
analyze what Bernie's entrance means for
the Democrat Party then the radical left
goes after the Duke John Wayne forty
years after John Wayne died and a
feminist pastor meltdown purity ring's
to give a genital shaped statue to
Gloria Steinem I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
let's to get to today but first let's
make a little money honey with movement
you know it's that time it's that time
to talk about my favorite watch movement
you know them they are founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank they've sold almost 2 million
launches worldwide by bringing quality
designs at fair prices so I love this
style the most this is the coolest style
by far it is the revolver this is the
Atlas I just like it more compliments on
this watch than any other watch I have
ever owned it's super cool super sleek
it's it it's like a retro kind of case
on it but a very modern sleek minimalist
design it just looks great these guys
really know what they're doing they now
have a mechanical watch the arc line
which is super cool so if you're if
you're like a real watch fiend and you
like the inner workings of watches
that's an automatic movement watch
really cool at a great price movement
watches are all about looking good while
keeping it simple and this is a
crowd-funded startup it was started by
college dropouts and have they've sold
watches in over 160 countries they
started just 95 bucks you're looking at
4 to 500 bucks if you were to buy this
in a traditional department store but
these guys take it right to you clean
design minimal really quality products
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
cough fac o VF e fe movements launching
new styles on their site all the time
check out their latest at MVM t-dot-com
slash cough fac o VF e f e join the
movement we knew this was inevitable
bernie sanders has entered the 2020
presidential race this is a wonderful
day I can't wait one of the most
colorful Bolshevik totalitarian
characters of the 2016 race he's now
back in for 2020 he's even older he's
even crazier here is Bernie Sanders
announcing through a big Twitter based
video ad his race for the presidency
real change
Devin takes place from the top on down
but always from the bottom on
Bernie Sanders health care for all idea
is gaining steam free tuition free
college tuition free tuition champion at
senator Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders
added the greatest threat to national
security is climate change the future of
our planet is at stake Sanders taking on
Amazon Fergus Sanders has been
consistent hammering about income
inequality
nobody should be living in poverty so
economy is rigged we have a campaign
finance system which is corrupt Sanders
leading the charge to stop her against
Annan the first time ever the Senate has
voted to ending unauthorized war the
fight against injustice has been the
work of his life the work of his life
now actually there's been very little
work in Bernie Sanders his life because
he's never held a job in the private
sector Bernie Sanders has worked for the
government since 1981 and even before
that he was kind of bumbling around
occasionally holding a job here or there
he was mostly a professional activist
this guy as much as one can in life make
it without ever holding a job Bernie
Sanders has never held a job so there
isn't very much work to his life and by
the way he's worked most of his life in
the government I actually don't even
attack that per se look plenty of people
have done plenty of good work in the
government Winston sure she'll spent
most of his life working for the
government and he did a lot of good work
the trouble is that Bernie Sanders has
not only not accomplished anything in
the private sector he has also not
accomplished anything in the public
sector
he has never accomplished anything he
has been in the government since 1981
he's almost been in the government now
for 40 years what does he have to show
for it the closest thing that he can
list as an accomplishment in 40 years of
government service is that he voted to
end some of our support for the Saudi
Arabian war in Yemen which by the way
didn't work so the thing is referring
you probably never even heard of this
story because it's a Nothing story
Bernie's
Sanders voted to invoke the War Powers
Act of 1973 to cut off the ability of
the White House to give military aid to
Saudi Arabia for their war in Yemen then
the house didn't vote on that and then
it went nowhere that's it that's that's
his biggest accomplishment he voted
based on a law that was passed in 1973
in the Senate to tell the White House to
stop giving extra money to the Saudis
for the study is to take care of a
conflict they have in Yemen and then the
house didn't vote for it no one know
where the biggest accomplishment in his
public life otherwise what else does
this tell us it checks all of the boxes
obviously he harps on climate change or
global warming or global cooling or
whatever euphemism you want to use for
it this is essential this is going to
separate the wheat from the chaff in the
Democrat primary it is not possible to
run for president as a Democrat in 2020
without centering your campaign on
climate change this is for a couple of
reasons one
it's the left's religion it fulfills all
the categories of religion it answers
some of their religious longings to save
the planet for original sin for penance
for indulgences it's for transcendent
reality that is what the the purpose of
global warming is in the left-wing
psychology but in the left-wing politics
and the actual implementing of a
political agenda the reasons global
warming or climate change is central is
because it very conveniently gives the
left everything they've always wanted in
politics a collectivist economics
nationalization of various industries
massive expansion of the federal
government massive diminishment of
individuals rights in America a basic
overturning of our political tradition
and our Democratic Republic a far
greater expansion of government power
and bureaucratic power over the rights
of state governments local governments
and individuals in the family this is
what they want so that's what he's going
to focus on okay that's fine
it's the evidence by the way that the
Democrat Party is not focusing on any
substantive issues in 2020 they're not
talking about the economy they're not
talking about foreign policy they're not
talking about entitlement spending or
the national debt or even trade they're
talking about the fantasy of the Sun
monster coming in and destroying the
whole world unless we vote for them and
then we'll save the world so they're
gonna Center this campaign around
fantasy and it's gonna produce terrific
results I cannot wait for that debate
stage where they're all arguing with one
another over whatever fever dream they
had the night before about the end of
the world and it's going to happen in
ten years no it'll happen in eight years
no it'll happen tomorrow and then it'll
happen tomorrow we'll all wait for the
world to end and it won't end the other
thing that is so quintessentially
leftist and Democrat about Bernie's
announcement ad is the focus on slogans
so the very first thing in the ad it
says change always happens from the
bottom up not the top down and the the
left all loves slogans they focus all
the time on slogans that sound like they
mean something but don't mean anything
at all so during the Bush years you
heard no war for oil meaning the Iraq
war we fought the Iraq war to steal a
lot of oil from Iraq never mind that we
never got the oil we didn't get good
contracts for the oil we are still in
the Middle East we're still in Africa we
went to Afghanistan not a whole lot of
oil in Afghanistan never mind that they
say no war for oil as if the the very
fact of they're saying this slogan would
create the reality that is only in their
fantasy Bernie says change never happens
from the top down of course it does the
American Revolution happened from the
top down you had extraordinarily elite
well-educated brilliant wealthy men with
a lot of leisure time crafting this
Republic and they were only able to
craft this Republic because they were
extraordinarily well-educated and they
were the elite so they had all read
their Cicero
the way up to John Locke they were able
to craft this brilliant system of
government they were extraordinarily
learning they they wrote thousands of
letters they were just brilliant men how
were they how did the Revolution begin
it began not because of these popular
uprisings exactly it began because
different colonial delegations came
together and said we need to form our
own government
there are countless more examples of
this of change happening from the top
down I just it is funny that our our own
country began that way and Bernie
Sanders obviously not the most
historically literate person isn't aware
of that he then takes the slogans up to
11 in the next part of the ad an
education not jails and incarceration
[Applause]
jobs and education not jails and
incarceration what what on earth does
that mean and education not je as though
jobs and education or opposed to jails
and incarceration if you have jobs in
education you can't possibly have jails
and incarceration and vice versa let me
give you a counter example Dylan roof in
the Year 2015
shot up a black church in Charleston
because he hated black people and wanted
to start a race war so now he's in jail
should we take him out of jail and give
him a job and put him in school because
we don't want jail and incarceration
Bernie just told us no jail and
incarceration instead of jail and
incarceration we're gonna have jobs in
education so we should take a
mass-murdering racist bigot out of jail
and give him a job in education right
unless hold on
and I'm just free-balling here maybe
jobs and education are not opposed to a
criminal justice system actually maybe
jobs and education require a criminal
justice system to main maintain order in
a society and keep civil society going
just a thought it's one of those slogans
because it rhymes leftists think that it
means something it does it would it's
like saying Ted Ted Bundy was a serial
kill her right Siri there's that show
about him now serial killer targeted
women crazed misogynist necrophile
murdered a bunch of young women he
shouldn't have ever been in jail
certainly shouldn't have been killed
right we should put jobs in education we
should stop punishing criminals and
actually give them jobs and products of
the welfare system that's the solution
right Ted Ted Bundy and Dylan roof give
them a job put them in school it's
justice justice according to Bernie
Sanders or we can put workers in jobs
and students in school and criminals in
prison that's my radical campaign pledge
that's my platform that I'm running on
jobs it would be like saying jobs and
education not hot dogs and vacation sure
well it rhymes
so I guess does that did he say
something that meant anything it it does
rhyme jobs in education not hot dogs on
vacation it that has the same semantic
value as jobs and education not jails
and incarceration we've got a lot more
to get to we got to get to that next
slogan but first let's talk about joy
bird have you heard about the revolution
in online furniture shopping and joy
bird the company behind it all joy bird
believes you should never settle when it
comes to your home furnishings that you
should always have the freedom to be
boldly original from idea to reality
they empower you to create the space and
furniture that brings you joy I love joy
bird I have two beautiful pieces of
furniture from joy bird everything about
it is meticulous it that we worked with
joy bird they designed the furniture
it's exactly right I've got them now two
pieces in my little reading nook and
whenever people come over to my home
they always complement that furniture
just a little offensive to me because I
have other furniture in my apartment
that I also spent time thinking about
but in that case I was really the one
driving and they never complement that
furniture it's always joy bird though
it's just really high-quality stuff
really sleek and they just take a lot of
care it's meticulous you get
one-of-a-kind furniture made to your
unique taste from mid-century modern to
contemporary classics free personal
design consultants quality handcrafted
365-day home trial skip this furniture
store and bring the showroom home free
returns within two weeks of delivery
see how joy bird is revolutionaries and
online furniture shopping create the
furniture that brings you joy today at
joy bird comm slash MKS joy bird comm /
MKS received an exclusive offer for 25%
off your first order using the code M K
s so Bernie has another slogan he says
we're not going to retreat on women's
rights what he's talking about is
abortion he's saying we're not going to
retreat on killing babies now he has to
use the euphemism women's rights now
it's obviously not rights for the
half-million baby girls that are killed
every year in the womb what happened to
their women's rights none nothing
he refuses to protect those if the the
way that you know that the left is
missing the mark the way that they know
that they're they're misleading you the
way that you know that they're trying to
deceive you is they always use
euphemisms and that sometimes they have
them rhymes sometimes they're in slogans
but it's those euphemisms we're not
going to retreat on women's rights how
about we advance the rights of the
half-million baby girls who were killed
in the womb each year Bernie Sanders
can't talk about that and then then
after he's talking about how we have to
kill a lot of babies he then goes back
and says that we have to stop this awful
inhumane child detainment policy of the
Trump administration that includes
protecting doctoral recipients and
comprehensive immigration reform you
don't rip little children away from the
arms of their money what you do is you
rip them out of the womb and then you
leave them on the table while the doctor
and the mother talk about what they want
to do with the kid and then you kill it
I was just talking to Virginia Governor
Ralph Northam and he told me you do not
rip the babies out of their mother's
arms you rip them out of the womb he
didn't put that part got left on the
cutting room floor Bernie Sanders's add
this this one this under the babies so
the cute little kids at the border this
is a boilerplate Democrat talking point
don't separate the kids from their
parents or the coyote random adults that
are carrying them and trafficking them
across the border who are not related to
the kids at all don't talk about that
one even Bernie Sanders won't go all the
way
this point he says it's terrible to rip
the kids from their parents arms okay
why do we rip the kids from their
parents arms we do it because of an
agreement the Flores settlement from the
Clinton administration from 1997 the
Flores settlement said that you can't
imprison children so the parents break
the law they they cross into our country
illegally foreign nationals here
illegally not a points of entry they run
across the border you then take the
parents you have to hold them in the
criminal justice system because they
broken the law but the parents are with
the kids so can you bring the kids into
the jails as well no what the courts
decided was that the kids need to be in
a nicer place so then the kids are held
in a separate facility Health and Human
Services runs those facilities so okay
now you've got to separate the parents
what is the alternative you have two
alternatives either you imprison the
kids with their parents or you let
everybody go and you have functionally
open borders and as long as some coyote
has got a kid under his arms he's not
arrested he's allowed to come into the
country illegally he has the opportunity
to access welfare all of our services do
whatever he wants no checks no health
checks no criminal background checks we
don't know if he's got drugs on him no
let him go
those are the two options imprisoned
kids or open borders and even Bernie
Sanders even radical Bernie Sanders will
not go all the way there and this brings
us to another point which is that Bernie
Sanders is a real politician we forget
this we think he's the outsider he know
he's been a professional politician for
forty years and one of the hallmarks of
being a politician is he takes credit
for things that other people do Amazon
Amazon will raise its minimum wage to 15
bucks an hour
350,000 workers thousands of workers at
Disney World will get raises it's a
victory for Bernie Sanders it's a
victory for all of us it's a victory for
Bernie Sanders why I don't know what did
he do it's not doesn't run Amazon he
doesn't work for Amazon he pressured
them okay so fine for him he's taking
credit for other people's
accomplishments
that's the socialist way that's the
Bernie Sanders way now he's talking
specifically about the minimum wage
what minimum wage does Bernie Sanders
suggest we have a very very very small
percentage of workers make the minimum
wage in this country the minimum wage is
not designed to support a family of four
the minimum wage is not designed to be
what you make at age 70 the minimum wage
is designed specifically for young kids
people who are working their way up out
of poverty people who are just getting
started in the workforce that that is
what the minimum wage is for its and
you're not supposed to be there forever
eventually you're supposed to move up
and the vast majority of Americans make
make more than the minimum wage but how
does he think the minimum wage works
what does he suggest because right now
they're talking about fight for 15 $15
an hour minimum wage but why stop at 15
why shouldn't we make the minimum wage
$20 an hour mm-hmm it's certainly better
it's very hard to live on $15 an hour
probably a lot easier to live on $20 an
hour or actually why stop there why not
make the minimum wage $30 an hour for
$30 an hour you can live really pretty
well on third well except what if you
got three or four kids I'm thirty
dollars an hour but maybe okay I'll tell
you what let's make the minimum wage
$100 an hour why not you're just raising
the wage you're just giving more money
to workers what could possibly go wrong
Oh a lot could go wrong because the
minimum wage destroys jobs there is a
cost to the minimum wage I know this is
shocking to socialists who think money
falls out of the gumdrop trees but costs
have costs so when you raise labor costs
that has a cost that has an effect on
the labor market it doesn't effect
on employers behavior so there was a
study there was a comprehensive 182 page
summary of research done over the last
two decades put together by economists
David Newmarket UC Irvine and William
washer at the Federal Reserve Board it
determined that a this is a
meta-analysis of all these other studies
85% of the best research points to a
loss of jobs following increases to the
minimum wage of course this makes sense
raising the minimum wage doesn't mean
that all of a sudden employers have more
money to use okay when they raise the
minimum wage so now we just have more
money magically to pay workers know when
you raise the minimum wage you raise the
labor costs for employers so what does
that mean you can either reduce the
number of workers so you keep the same
costs of labor or is they you just lay
people off or your or your you can go
out of business I guess that's another
option or you can shift more money from
labor into capital investments so this
happened in McDonald's that raise the
minimum wage in Seattle I believe it was
and all of a sudden you see workers
getting laid off and they start
investing in those electronic ordering
kiosks where now you can go up and order
your regular muffin on a kiosk okay
great so now some people get a $15
minimum wage the other guy is laid off
because there is no such thing as a
minimum wage we might create statutes
that mandate a certain minimum wage the
true minimum wage is zero dollars an
hour because you do not have a right to
a job you don't have the right to some
employer just giving you money for no
reason another there's an American
action forum study showed that the fight
for $15 minimum wage kills 261 thousand
jobs held mostly by poor undertrained
undereducated young suburban Millennials
and minority teens in the first phase
but once the fight for 15 is implemented
across the country it will cost our
economy 1.7 million jobs Bernie Sanders
doesn't mention that it's just all
vacuous vapid slogans and then he closes
us all off on the most vacuous slogans
of all
we have a lot of work in front of us
[Music]
if we are prepared to stand together
there is no end to what the great people
of our nation can accomplish so then he
just ends the last 15-second of this ad
says nothing we need to stand together
we will accomplish things what we'll do
we'll it'll be really good and stand
together and be and hotdogs and
vacationers from the last slogan he was
using this shows you that the myriad
comparisons from the mainstream media
between Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders
are wrong they don't really make sense
we you heard this all throughout 2016
well really bernie is a lot like Trump
actually president Trump somewhat
cynically embraced this comparison in an
attempt to turn Democrat voters off to
Hillary Clinton but the comparison does
not really hold Donald Trump is a
political outsider he never held public
office until two and a half years ago -
I'm certain no actually I guess two
years ago two years ago in one month was
when he was sworn in as president until
that time he had never held public
office before Bernie Sanders has held
public office for 41 years Bernie
Sanders only speaks in vague slogans
because he knows the reality of what
he's proposing we'll turn off all of
America it's radical it's awful it
doesn't make any sense President Trump
speaks in if anything language that is
too blunt too direct he's speaking in
very graphic very tangible terms we are
going to build a big wall it will be ten
feet higher Mexico is going to pay for
it we are going to renegotiate this
trade deal we're gonna renegotiate this
trade deal we're gonna make this plant
stay in America we are going to put this
person in prison if anything is being
too specific but it's exactly the
opposite of what you are getting from
Bernie Sanders so that I am personally
offended by the comparisons of Bernie
Sanders this ridiculous old socialist
coot who has never accomplished a thing
in his life to President Trump who's
been highly effective and is far more
honest with voters
can Bernie go anywhere polling suggests
he can he's always ranked in the top
three contenders in terms of possible
Democrat nominees the trouble is that
those polls at the moment are mostly
based on name identification so people
know his name because he made it pretty
far in 2016 that is gonna change
necessarily as people like Kamala Harris
Spartacus laia watha Klobuchar as these
people gain greater name recognition
Bernie's is going to decrease
he's also 77 years old he's just very
very old to be running for president
he'll that means it's 2019 he'll be
inaugurated at the age of 78 he'll be 82
by the end of his first term if he
serves two terms he'd be 86 by the end
of his second term very very old the way
you know it's probably not gonna go very
far he's already gotten me to do so
burnt I don't think Bernie Sanders is
like a groper I did see a pretty gross
video of him singing communist songs and
Russia shirtless that was the most I've
ever been sexually harassed by Bernie
Sanders but he's been me too there's
been a a pretty dirty campaign to accuse
his staffers of sexually harassing
people basically trying to kick him out
of the 2020 race that is populated by a
lot of women the other reason he's gonna
have trouble is there's no more Hillary
Clinton to kick around anymore Hillary
Clinton was the best argument for
Democrats to vote for Bernie Sanders
Hillary Clinton was a singularly
despised woman even by her own party
she's gone and now you've got all these
fresh-faced Democrat women who don't
have the baggage of Hillary Clinton I
think it's just gonna kill him me
Bernie Sanders he might be a Bolshevik
all the way but he is an old straight
white man this is for a party that has
embraced identity politics and
intersectionality it's probably gonna
kill him speaking of older white men we
of course have Howard Schultz but we've
got to take a break then I will defend
another very old white man so old that
he's been dead for 40 years John Wayne
and if we have time we'll get to the
feminist pastor who melted down a bunch
of purity ring's to make a genital
statue for Gloria Steinem but it's
almost time for our next episode of the
conversation featuring little ol me
Michael Knowles today
7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific I will be
taking all of your questions every query
that is burned in your hearts and
answering them live on air Plus Alicia
kress will be there too as always this
episode will be free for everyone to
watch on Facebook and YouTube but only
subscribers can ask the questions
once again subscribe to get your
questions answered by yours truly today
at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific and
join the conversation if you're on
Facebook and YouTube go over to daily
wire calm 10 bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you know what you get
all sorts of stuff me the Andrew Clavin
show the ben shapiro show the Matt Walsh
show questions in the mailbag that will
be coming up on Thursday questions in
the conversation questions backstage
that's coming up soon to another Kingdom
you get everything you get this you get
the leftist tears tumblr this is very
good and we will never never see a
feminist pastor melting this down to
make genital shaped statues for Gloria
Steinem because the leftist here's
tumblr don't melt go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back with a lot more
Howard Shultz former Starbucks CEO
lifelong Democrat but he's not a crazy
lefty he's gonna be running an
independent campaign for president who
knows anything could happen
he is really signaling to the right and
to centrists to come on over to his
campaign he's really ratcheting up the
rhetoric against the extreme left here
is a blog post heat he put out just
yesterday it says quote the stakes are
too high
to cross our fingers and hope the
Democratic Party nominates a moderate
who can win over enough independence and
disaffected Republicans and even fellow
Democrats to defeat Trump next year that
any opponent can oust Trump no matter
how far to the radical left they are is
a fallacy very strong words I like that
he's embracing this language coming out
against the radical left I think that
there are a lot of people who could go
along with this because there is a big
difference now between the composition
of the right-wing today as the
composition of the right-wing say in the
1970s or 80s the conservative movement
has changed its character in the 1950s
60s 70s you had what Bill Buckley called
fusion ISM he brought together people
who were basically all anti-communists
so you had the traditionalists you had
the libertarians you had the hawkish
Democrats and left wingers the Blue Dog
Democrats you had even the religious
right came in you had all of these
people who didn't really agree with each
other about much but they were all
anti-communist and so the the concern
for conservatives today is after the
fall of the Berlin Wall what is that one
thing that unites the conservative
movement ever since 91 92 the
conservative movement hasn't made a ton
of sense
libertarians traditionalists the
religious right the neoconservatives the
what they don't actually have very much
in common
so you've seen different fights over the
soul of the conservative movement
different fights between a staff
Bushman Tyrians and populist soar all of
these different groups because they
don't have that unifying enemy anymore
what is that gonna be right now I'm not
so sure when you look at the right today
it seems like one unifying issue is free
speech so this is something we can all
get behind Dave Rubin and I actually
don't agree on that much but we're on
the same side
we're always he comes on my show we are
you know and always tweeting each other
we're on the same side of the internet
political debates because we have this
opponent which is the censorious left
the totalitarian left okay free speech
is one good issue but I think a lot of
those people who would now call
themselves right-wing or on the new
right I think a lot of them at least for
now they'll probably come over later on
would be a little more libertarian or a
little more classically liberal or a
little more centrist or a little more
independent they don't really go whole
hog into the depth of conservative
thought and Howard Schultz could speak
to these guys it's the classic I'm a
fiscal conservative but a social liberal
moon I'm more conservative but not that
kind of conservative Howard Schultz
actually could speak to those people I
really think he could once you say well
I've got certain libertarian leanings he
he is making a pitch not to the left
explicitly not to the left he's making
his points so explicit in this blog post
he is making a pitch to the new right to
the tube LexA to the walk away to the
Democrats and disaffected people who
would have called themselves left-wing
even five years ago who are now moving
to the right he's making the pitch for
the new right and it has a chance of
working
except that Donald Trump is speaking to
those people because Donald Trump also
is not a Burkean conservative
necessarily I actually think he has more
conservative leanings than people are
willing to admit but I don't think he
sits around at the Federalist Society
and wears bowties and smoked cigars and
sips his brandy that's not the kind of
conservative that Donald Trump is he's a
very practical guy and part of that
practice
Galatea's he's speaking to those same
people that schultz is speaking to
they're going after the same voters and
Donald Trump is very effective at it so
I think Howard Schultz is probably bound
to lose but he's he's only bound to lose
because of the current Republican that
he's going up against if he were going
up against a more ideologically rigid
conservative or against a more
doctrinaire conservative or a more
traditional conservative in his behavior
then I actually think Howard Schultz
would have a pretty good case to make e
to actually have a real chance of
shaking up 2020 but that that is the
question and once you get past Trump
what does the future of American
politics look like what does the future
of the political divide look like he
goes on in his blog post he says those
so concerned about a centrist
independent being a spoiler should
perhaps ask another question will the
eventual Democratic nominee be the
party's own version of a spoiler has the
democrat party moved so far left
alienated so many people who like dave
like dave rubin
or like many others or Candace Owens
says that she she had her conservative
awakening more like other people who say
I'm leaving the left and I want to bring
other people along with me is the
Democrat Party radicalizing in such a
way that it is its own spoiler and does
that leave room open not for a new party
on the right but actually a new party on
the left all the talk of never Trump and
oh the end of conservatism with a
capital C and a trade mark and an I NC
after it for all the talk of the right
splitting up really I think the question
is is there room for a new party on the
Left Howard Schultz is gonna try to talk
about that speaking of the radical left
I did not expect to have to be defending
John Wayne 40 years after the Duke died
but the modern left is a very strange
beast and so this is what I find myself
doing I wake up this morning I open up
my Twitter and I see that the left is
attacking John Wayne John Wayne has been
dead since the 1970s 1970
I think he died what are they attacking
him for because in 1971 was it
he's seven-year eight years from death
he gives an interview to playboy in
which he expressed the views of very
many people at that time over forty
years ago I guess nearly fifty years ago
at this point from the interview about
race relations in America so what did he
say he said quote I'll try to do in my
John Wayne voice with a lot of blacks
there's quite a bit of resentment along
with their descent and possibly
rightfully so but we can't all of a
sudden get down on our knees and turn
everything over to the leadership of the
blacks I believe in white supremacy
until the blacks are educated to a point
of responsibility I don't believe in
given authority and positions of
leadership and judgment to irresponsible
people it's not it's not a great John
Wayne it's sort of more of an impression
than an impersonation ok I'm not it's
like the come on cut me some slack
that's what he says and cut John Wayne
some slack by the way for what he said
this is an interview of a man born in
1907 given immediately after the tumult
of the civil rights movement civil
rights movement lasts what the mid-50s
to the late 60s 68 69 you're talking to
a man in 1971 a man who is like the
definition of old-school tough American
ideas he's at the end of his life and by
the way John Wayne is making a cogent
point about racism what is the point
that John Wayne is making here
he says the very first line he says well
there's a lot of blacks with a lot of
blacks there's quite a bit of resentment
along with their descent and possibly
rightfully so he's not saying they have
nothing to complain about what are they
and they shouldn't completely they have
been treated perfectly in this country
and there's been no slavery and there's
been no exclusion no he doesn't say that
he says very possibly rightfully so
they are resentful of this country right
what is the implication of that the
implication
is that they have been excluded from
education this is true this was one of
the claims of the civil rights movement
but actually one of the goals of the
civil rights movement was equality in
education John Wayne says blacks have
been excluded from education in the
United States and so by necessity by
definition they're going to be excluded
from the leadership of the country and
so as they're then included in
educational systems and other social
systems from which they were excluded
then over time they can be brought in to
the political leadership of the country
this is actually an anti-racist point
that he's making he is acknowledging the
reality of racial exclusion and he is
saying that this is now changing and
will change over time the point that
John Wayne is making and the way that it
has been totally perverted for no reason
by the left because the left has no
actual problems to complain about so
they have to go back 40 years to create
their own problems and pretend that this
is a big deal this point was made by
Russell Kirk in his book the
conservative mind which I'm going back
over as a tremendous book he points out
he puts it in different words but he
points out that the leftist reformer
looks into some opinion from the past or
some institution and asks is it true and
the conservative the intelligent person
looks into that opinion or that
institution or that law or whatever and
asks what does it mean these are very
different schools you know if this is
how the Left approaches history it's how
it approaches literature it resembles
what Harold Bloom the literary critic
would call the school of resentment they
look back at literature and they'll and
they read it and they hate it and they
just hate it and they're looking to hate
it and they want to hate it and they
want to debunk it and deconstruct it and
point out why it's wrong and terrible
the normal way the reasonable rational
way to look back at history and
literature and history is to look back
and say what can I learn from this what
wisdom is there to take from this what
point
is this person making is this person
challenging my own assumptions does this
person have something to teach me only
then can you reject what what is not
valuable in that opinion or that
institution or that statute only once
you understand it can you have any sense
of what to reject you have to master it
first you have to approach it with some
humility and awe and then you can say
okay I've absorbed this I see where he's
going I see why he thought that I see
the value of why he thought that and now
I'm going to change this part or dispute
this part or okay that's a rational way
to do it John there are some videos on
it you can check out videos of
late-stage john wayne at talking about
minorities there's actually a great
story of him who knows if it's
apocryphal or not he's on his deathbed
he's got he's got some friends coming
over one of whom is Jewish and the
Jewish guy says to Wayne I didn't I
didn't think you'd want to see me you
know I don't think you'd want to see a
Jew while you're sick and John Wayne
allegedly said the only Jew I don't want
to see is the big one in the sky this is
there he had a kind of reputation as a
funny crank you know a funny curmudgeon
who would make racial jokes and wasn't
out of some animus or anything here is a
John Wayne speaking explicitly on camera
about issues of race and minorities
being represented by men who are kowtow
to minorities where they can get votes
and I think it's bad for for our country
and I I'm sad to see minorities make so
much of themselves as a hyphenated
American I wish they all get to thinking
that they're Americans as they should
and as if luckily been born here and
couldn't be better off in any other
place they shouldn't there shouldn't be
some explaining and bellyache in the
late 60s and early 70s there was a
period of considerable change civil
rights for blacks equal rights for women
cuz this made America a better place I
am saddened by the fact that although we
were a matriarchy I think we will not be
any longer I think opening doors and
tipping her had the lady's sister
probably a thing of the past thing the
forerunners of the women's liberation of
today have have taken that feeling away
from me everything Mary man show me the
lie
show me the lion what he just said I
think people are gonna watch that and
they're gonna approach it with that
school of resentment they're going to
say how can I be offended how can I
pretend to be offended by what he said
okay he said leftist politicians are
pandering to racial minorities against
their own interests Oh hmm wait a minute
that's exactly what they do
they panderer that they stoke racial
resentment they pander and divide up
Americans along those lines racial
sexual lines then they end up hurting
the people that ostensibly they were
intending to help okay that part was
true all right that's fine he says that
people born in America are better off
than people anywhere else in the world
that ya know that's true too that's even
people historically excluded from
society or better off in America then
not in America because America is the
greatest country in the world and once
you have after the period of slavery
once people
free once you eradicate Jim Crow once
you eradicate exclusion and
discrimination by law or mostly
eliminate discrimination by law or even
go a good distance toward eliminating
discrimination by law people are
choosing to be here they're choosing to
be here for a reason it's the most
equitable just prosperous country in
history of the world people are better
off being born here than being born in
Pakistan in the 1950s or today better
off being born here than in Rwanda in
the 1970s but of course they are America
is the greatest country in the world
that's why we have an immigration
problem because everybody on planet
earth wants to come here of every single
color of the rainbow of every sexual
nature and preference of course so that
part's exactly right - what does he say
America used to be a matriarchy and it's
not anymore also true this is a radical
point that feminists are only quickly
learning since the beginning of the
modern feminist movement the second wave
feminist movement female happiness is
measured by every single survey has
declined both relative to the happiness
of men and in absolute terms why is it
because America was a matriarchy a
matriarchy in the sense that women are
the center of the world of the political
world everything that happens in
commerce in politics everything in the
military is to protect women and to
protect the next generation the hand
that rocks the cradle rules the world it
is a disgusting Society that won't hold
a door for a woman a disgusting Society
that won't show women grace tip their
hat to a woman won't even consider
standing up when they leave the table
that's a disgusting Society that's an
anti woman society John Wayne makes that
point and then he goes on he makes his
central Duke point about belly aching
and I want to see them have everything I
want
I don't squawk and crybaby and say geez
I had to go without meals when I was 16
and 17 years old it's a terrible thing I
don't think that that the you should
look back in Hawaiian and bellyache or
try to hold somebody else guilty for
everything you did
damn right Duke absolutely right he
opens up on the just on the racial point
because I know people are gonna try to
take it out of context he says I want
them to have everything also it's
terrible to complain and it is it is
disgusting to complain awful it is
sinful it is wrong it is miserable don't
complain
quit your belly aching everybody goes
through tough things some people suffer
more than others some people suffer a
lot during acute periods of time and
then they don't suffer much later on
soompi it just differs everybody goes
through tough things stop whining about
it you little children stop it there's
nothing good about it there's nothing
virtuous about complaining there's
nothing nice about it there's nothing
good there's nothing beautiful it's just
gross fix your circumstances advocate
for the good do the right thing all of
those are wonderful things but don't
indulge yourself in self-pity good lord
that's the point Dukes making he's
absolutely right and the left just can't
hear it we'll get to feminist genital
statue purity ring's tomorrow I guess I
guess we don't have time today we'll get
to all of that later in the meantime
check out the conversation that's coming
up later today
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
of era production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19